hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my fear the walking dead
episode 3 QA and some stuff from season
six Robert Kirkman was just talking
about some of his characters and how he
thinks some of the TV show characters
have become way better than their comic
book versions if it wasn't glaringly
obvious i'm talking about Carol
pelletier Morgan Jones and he also
referenced Darrell but technically
Darrell is an exception because he's not
in the comic book but you get the idea
he was trying to say that sometimes the
show you know even though it diverges
from the comic books and changes things
it dives really deep into specific
moments that he didn't explore that much
in the comic the tease that he gave for
season six is that they're gonna dive
really deep he called it a beloved comic
book storyline that he didn't really
explore too much in the comics take that
with a grain of salt I think he's
talking about hilltop and they actually
did explore that quite a bit in the
comics but I think he said that they're
going to be focusing specifically on a
particular arc during season six they're
not going to be traveling all over the
place like they were in previous seasons
you guys can let me know what storyline
that is so beloved from the comics do
you think the Kirkman is talking about
so here we go on to questions just
careful for spoilers from fear the
walking dead if you haven't seen episode
3 yet first question it's Joker asks do
you think that the plane that was flying
at the end is the one that's going to be
in the online episode soon so yeah AMC
announced that they're introducing a new
character to fear the walking dead using
this standalone thing that they're going
to put on the web what it's going to
happen is is it's going to be like
walkers on a plane they're going to tell
the story of these people having to deal
with a walker outbreak on a plane and
they're gonna they're going to post it
online it's not going to be on TV they
didn't say exactly when they're gonna
post it but I'm guessing it's going to
be sometime between the end of fear the
walking dead in the beginning of season
2 of that show they haven't said if they
filmed it or not but I think that
they're done filming fear the walking
dead so they probably already started
production to that stand alone thing and
I don't know if it's going to be a full
half-hour or not it probably won't be
they did webisodes for the main show a
couple seasons ago and they're just like
really short little bits of digital
content so I'm thinking it's gonna be
the same type of thing it'd be great if
it were samuel jackson although that's
never gonna happen too many damn walkers
on this goddamn plane next question eben
ezer asks why don't they just plan on
escaping from the military with the
junkie leading them so you're talking
about like it at the end you know why
don't they get out instead of get
trapped I think there probably is going
to be so freaked out they're not going
to know what to do right away like
they'll be so blindsided by
the guns that the military has there's
something about a bunch of people
holding a bunch of guns in your face
that makes it harder for you to process
information so I'm guessing it'll take
them a while to regroup but there will
probably be a plan to get out next
question Chantelle asks is it me or did
they set up either Liza or Madison that
will be dead by the end of the season
I'm referring to when Madison told Liza
to kill her if she turned well the
actually the title of the finale implies
that somebody's going to die like the
good person said that good person always
dies first the red flag right now is on
Travis just because he seems like he's
the good man like he's trying to do all
the right things and be the good person
don't kill our neighbor she's our friend
don't do something you can't take back
that that's something that someone with
a really good heart would say so by
Daniel's logic he would be the first
person to die now the title could be a
red herring the good man could be a
reference to someone not being a good
man any more like you're choosing a
darker path I really like Cliff Curtis
he's an amazing actor I hope he makes it
to season two but he's not going to make
it the way his character is acting right
now next question Phil asks while
conspiracy theory Daniel seems pretty
clued up on what's happening Paul
Daniels family from El Salvador's dead
been in worse situations it's too late
have they seen this all before so you're
kind of wondering if they've seen a
version of the outbreak before no I
don't think that they have I think that
he just came from a really terrible
place in El Salvador and he's trying to
escape that so he has an idea of how
things get when society breaks down
there isn't a ton that we know about his
life before he lived in America he seems
like somebody who emigrated to America
like he came fleeing a bad situation in
his home country so when he says it's
too late he's probably remembering
something terrible from his past but I
don't think it has anything to do with
walkers next question gamer asks at an
estimate how long do you reckon it'll be
before either the military becomes
extremely violent or the outbreak
reaches the neighborhood in a more
prominent force so you're saying before
everything goes completely crazy I would
say maybe two episodes because people
like people on the right in the city
we're going crazy already they probably
are been turned by now you have to
remember the groups of other walkers
take down other people and grow the
Horde in an exponential rate one Walker
bites another those two by two more and
so on and so forth and if it's not
cleared the reason why these walkers are
moving faster than the walkers that we
see on the main show
it's because they have a lot more muscle
tissue that's one to Scott Gimple big
deals about Walker's in the walking dead
it's that their movement has to come
from muscles it has to come from tissue
they're not just walking skeleton so the
less decomposed that people are the
faster they'll move so cuts a couple
years down the road they'll be way more
decomposed they'll have a lot less
tissue they'll move way slower so with
all these fresh meat Walker's things are
gonna go to [ __ ] a lot faster next
question true blue asks the title of
episode 3 is the dog what do you think
the metaphor was if any well obviously
it was a metaphor to the dog dying you
know really horrible everybody kind of
turned away you know maybe some of you
turned the channel for a little bit but
also I think it's a metaphor for when
they put it in the ground and she blame
things on the dog so the military
wouldn't think that they're infected
using the titles of episodes have
multiple meanings you know practical and
metaphorical the metaphorical meaning i
think is blame it on the dog so you
don't get in trouble you know like oh
the dog made that mess please don't
shoot US military person next question
drew chronic asks I was wondering why
the cells our family didn't reach out to
the National Guard for some help with
the wife's leg well Daniel was probably
just trying to figure out what his next
move was like he probably thought things
were gonna get really bad really fast so
they were just kind of pausing before he
did go out and get help there's no way
that he's not going to get help they
just they need to find a way to explain
to the military people that she hasn't
been bitten by one of the walkers or her
injury isn't going to cause her to turn
I think the risk right now is that heber
if you were to like run right out and
say oh my god you know my wife needs
help her ankles crushed we don't know
what to do there's not a doctor nearby
they would probably like there's nothing
we can do to help her so let's put her
over here and then she would die right
away next question Toby asks how does
the infection spread besides biting but
mostly through human contact and is
probably airborne to sexual contact
breathing on other people being in
proximity to other people really really
anything next question Vegas asks has no
one in the world ever seen a zombie
movie they can't be that dumb well the
the Syria you have to remember that
Robert Kirkman the way he set this
universe up is that it's not really
self-aware like that it's not a comedy
like they would not be making jokes
about zombies what he was trying to do
with the comic and what they're trying
to do with the main series and now this
series is show how the world would react
to learning about zombies for the first
time and technically they're not zombies
are called walkers there's some
copyright in there somewhere
you really think about it like if the
characters knew exactly what to do in a
zombie outbreak or a walker outbreak
there wouldn't be much of a story it
would be more like a first-person
shooter with them just walking around
mowing stuff down and that's more with
the main series is fear The Walking Dead
is supposed to tell the story of how
they slowly figure that out next
question Zeb asks how do you think the
show will hit full blown apocalypse mode
it seems like now the military has
rolled out and kind of knows what's
happening and it seems unreasonable for
walkers to overrun everyone well I think
the issue is is that they're going to be
so many more walkers compared to the
amount of military they could still be
overrun with just masses and masses of
bodies and you have to remember there's
a certain amount of human error to like
every single soldier isn't going to be
super hardcore there's so many walkers
they're just going to zerg the military
at a certain point so it doesn't matter
how many guns they have thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do for
weeks to go before walking dead season
six starts i'm so excited i cannot wait
to see Carol stabbed the [ __ ] out of
somebody congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Shane Jones you want a
twenty dollar amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so and get your contact info
there's three more weeks of fear the
walking dead so it's going to be
business as usual till we get Walking
Dead Season 6 i might do a couple extra
Walking Dead videos the week of that
premiere Gotham season 2 also starts
next Monday so be sure to subscribe to
get everything just in case you guys
aren't caught up yet you can click here
for my fear the walking dead episode 3
video and you can click here to learn
all about what I think is going on a
game of thrones with Stannis and jon
snow at the end of season 5 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight